hey well here is some great news it's
good first
news this morning breaking news donnie
osmond has announced he is returning
to las vegas next year for his very
first
solo residency on the strip that's right
he's going to be performing at harrah's
from
august through november ladies come on
tickets go on sale
tuesday morning prices started just 65
donnie performed on the strip of course
as you know for 11 years with his sister
marie
and nearly a million fans attended their
shows
at the flamingo they were such a sold
out hit for
so long now donnie's just gonna take the
stage by himself until he can convince
marie to come back
see a little bit of country and a little
bit of rock and roll with him again what
do you guys think you think he'll be
solo for long
alex and uh and i i don't know my bet is
that she's gonna be back eventually
but we don't know yet yeah or at the
very least for maybe a special
performance special appearance yeah for
sure everyone that comes to visit
the first thing they always ask is is
donnie marie's you know are they still
on the side of the hotel
that's always the number one question
nate
yeah they finally got that taken down
and i know that uh sherry's big concern
is whether or not donnie will perform
with or without a shirt
and he would sing a song to you sherry
and that's go away little girl
i mean it's true let's be honest i think
well the good news is that it's a short
commute right
donnie from the flamingo to uh harrah's
is what a couple of doors away
essentially show
so all of his stuff from the old locker
room can just go from the dressing room
you just go right next door it's super
easy
much apparently sherry that's the way
sherry preferred that
no not at all i still have my hug from
him when he was in the studio
you know he came in and did the
interview i remember that i remember so
i had my big squeeze
yeah i know so do i nate
yes